pour la suite de cette émission spéciale
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
Benjamin Morel bonjour Benjamin merci
beaucoup d'être là et Frédéric David
bonjour Frédéric
hop Quentin évidemment nous a rejoint
comme tout le monde bonjour Quentin club
spécial je vous le disais des saisons du
Conseil constitutionnel attendu donc en
fin de journée quels sont les scénaris
possibles y a-t-il des motifs
d'inconstitutionnalité on verra ça
beaucoup avec vous Benjamin et quelles
conséquences pour la suite de mobilité
de la mobilisation Frédéric vous nous le
direz vous avez réalisé un sondage et
qu'attendent les Français de cette
décision on va bien sûr en parler tout
au long de ce club pour commencer
Benjamin je vais pas être sympa je vais
vous demander de vous mouiller un peu je
suis d'habitude je suis sympa mais là je
vous demande de vous mouiller un peu
quel est selon vous la décision la plus
probable je regrette de mettre
alors il y a des vrais motifs
d'inconsnalité si le Conseil veut il
peut clairement c'est à dire que la
procédure est pour le moins baroque tel
qu'elle a été utilisée ça pose un vrai
problème de lisibilité de sincérité du
débat parlementaire après au vu du
contexte politique au vu de la marge
d'interprétation du Conseil j'aurais
tendance malgré tout à parier beaucoup
plus sur une censure partielle une
censure de notamment des cavaliers
sociaux peut-être quelques réserves
d'interprétation en mode Scud pour bien
expliquer que la procédure a été pour le
moins baroque pour ne pas dire à ses
problématiques mais en revanche la
censure totale serait évidemment une
bombe à fragmentation lancée au dessus
de l'Élysée mais encore une fois il y a
des motifs clairement
si vous regardez évidemment l'usage pas
forcément très sain du 47e j'avais fait
une tribune dans Le Monde au début de
cette affaire pour expliquer qu'on
rentrait quand même là dans quelque
chose qui à terme pourrait être
dangereux en termes de comment est-ce
qu'on fait passer les réformes sociales
si vous regardez toutes les dispositions
de rationalisation qui ont été en mode
mitraillette lors de cette réforme un
certain nombre de points d'applications
notamment du Règlement du Sénat il s'est
passé des choses ici le fait que on est
invalidé des milliers de sous
amendements après avoir rédigé à peu
près dans les mêmes termes à un article
7 et bien normalement ça porte quelque
peu atteintes aux droits d'amendement
alors on peut dire oui mais obstruction
obstruction il y a eu une vingtaine de
milliers de d'amendements à l'Assemblée
je rappelle que sur la loi EDF en 2006
il y en a eu 138000 et au Sénat on ne
peut pas non plus qualifier ça
d'obstruction même si évidemment il y a
une volonté de faire durer les débats
comme sur tous les grands textes donc
les motifs sont là si le Conseil veut il
peut je crains qu'ils ne veuille point
on va en parler ça est-ce que Frédéric
vous qui qui percevez l'opinion mieux
que personne est-ce que les Français
croient vraiment à une censure totale de
ce texte alors déjà ce qui est
complètement inédite je vais répondre
plutôt sur la partie opinion je suis ni
juriste ni consiste donc ni
concessionnaliste c'est l'intérêt des
Français pour cette phase du conseil
festival ça restait un objet inconnu un
objet politique d'identifier si je puis
dire pour les Français j'ai regardé ce
qui s'était passé au moment du CPE très
peu de propos de français très faible
intérêt puisque la CPE avait je fais le
parallèle puisque c'est la dernière
grande réforme qui a été retirée enfin
non appliquez par un gouvernement un
gouvernement a cédé face à la rue
c'était Jacques Chirac et Dominique de
Villepin 2006 très peu d'intérêt pour
les Français là un intérêt extrêmement
fort et puis pour les opposants à cette
réforme qui reste extrêmement nombreux
les choses ont sont complètement figées
le soutien au moment cela c'était
l'enquête il faut Fiducial pour SUD
RADIO d'hier reste extrêmement fort et
symboliquement au même niveau 62% de
soutien ou de sympathie à ce qu'on me
par rapport à ce qu'on mesurait en 95
lors des mouvements anti réforme
Juppé là je suis frappé de voir
l'intérêt d'une part mais est-ce que
cette décision est je ne ferais aucun me
fait pronostic va trancher le No gordien
c'est à dire de cette réforme à laquelle
les Français s'opposent mais dont ils
ont intériorisé qu'elle serait
finalement appliquées j'ai envie de dire
non on a posé une question pour le JDD
que je trouvais extrêmement voilà
spectaculaire parce que si le Conseil
consiste valide est-ce que ça va être un
carburant pour le moment social pour
l'opposition à la réforme comme un peu
un effet 49-3 bis alors ça n'a rien à
voir ou bien est-ce que on va on va
poser les pancartes et dire on passe à
autre chose et ce qui est très
intéressant vous le voyez c'est à quel
point l'opinion est fracturée l'opinion
est divisée c'est en sac le negorien
n'est absolument pas tranché et qu'on
est toujours malgré cette étape du
Conseil constitutionnel dans une
véritable incertitude du côté des
testicules politiques du côté du
microcosme politique comédique et du
côté de l'opinion publique on pour finir
évidemment sur les conséquences sur la
suite du mouvement mais Benjamin
Frédéric le disait
les Français découvrent peut-être le
Conseil constitutionnel ou en tout cas
il n'a jamais été autant mis en lumière
le Conseil consuel est-ce que ça peut
peser sur la décision alors quand vous
prenez un petit peu les archives du
Conseil moi j'avais fait un travail sur
l'histoire du conseil notamment
l'ouverture des archives vous voyez que
malgré tout l'opinion c'est pas quelque
chose que le Conseil
ignore tout à fait par exemple si vous
prenez les archives sur la loi Veil
c'est toujours intéressant c'est un
exemple que j'utilise beaucoup parce que
profondément ils sont plutôt très
conservateurs la loi Veil ils ont pas
forcément très envie de la valider mais
ils savent très bien que ils iraient à
rebours de l'histoire de l'opinion etc
et donc finalement il trouve une façon
juridiquement de valider le texte et
donc malgré tout ça peut peser mais
attention il y a pas que ça évidemment
qui compte il y a un autre côté
évidemment les arguments juridiques qui
priment et ça je crois qu'il faut quand
même le dire le conseil ne juge pas en
pure opportunité pas en pure politique
les arguments sur le fond il faut il
faut bien préciser exactement il
disparaitre
à la fois sur le fond et sur la
procédure telle qu'elle est utilisée et
là et ben vous pouvez et c'est là où on
est fait il y a peut-être une question
politique même au sens noble à se poser
il y a une marge d'interprétation qui
est très forte parce que tout à l'heure
je vous ai dit oui il y a des vrais
billets d'inconscientalité clairement
mais en même temps toutes les
dispositions rationalisation qui ont été
utilisées pour le règlement du Sénat et
ben l'ont été dans leur forme
constitutionnelle mais c'est le cumul
c'est l'usage de disposition qu'on ne
voyait pas réellement pour une réforme
des retraites notamment ce fameux 47-1
qui pose problème et donc là il y a une
marge d'interprétation mais cette
démarche d'interprétation la question
qui est posée c'est qu'elles vont être
les conséquences politiques de la
décision et ces conséquences politiques
de la décision en termes de stabilité du
pays de gouvernabilité etc et ben c'est
un élément politique qui peut peser et
également et bien qui peut
potentiellement entre deux
interprétations qui sont possibles sur
le papier orienté la façon dont certains
membres vont pouvoir se positionner moi
j'avais une question pour vous Benjamin
puisque vous dites il y a cet
accumulation effectivement l'article 44
de 44 3 de la Constitution 47,1 article
38 du Règlement du salaire on avait vu
tout ça pendant l'examen des 10 jours de
la réforme
de groupe qui faisait voilà qui prenait
la parole qui disait en application d'un
cycle 44 Linéa 2 du règle de la
Constitution je demande est-ce qu'il n'y
ait plus qu'un orateur pour un orateur
contre etc et donc on avait appris
effectivement tous ces articles mais
est-ce que la Constitution dispose ou
interdit le cumul parce que en soi il y
a pas de règle sur le fait qu'on les
utilise ensemble ces articles non si
vous voulez si on regarde la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
sur le temps long il y a deux éléments
d'abord le Conseil constitutionnel tient
à ce qui est une lisibilité une
sincérité du débat pour ça vous devez
pas sur utiliser des dispositifs de
rationalisation au risque de priver le
Parlement de débat pris en un il y a pas
de problème est-ce que le cumul
représente un problème il y a pas de
réponse claire dans la jurisprudence le
deuxième élément c'est que le Conseil
est très tolérant vis-à-vis de l'usage
voire du MES usage des dispositions de
rationalisation s'il considère qu'il y a
obstruction obstruction elle-même qui
nuit la clarté à la lisibilité à la
sincérité des débats est-ce qu'il y a
réellement eu obstruction obstruction au
point que justement on utilise pas la
Grosse Bertha mais 30 grosses Bertha
pour écraser le débat parlementaire et
là c'est pas tout à fait évident vous
voyez ouais et donc
ce faisant là il y a une marge
d'interprétation d'accord moi je peux
pas vous dire en toute honnêteté si
c'est conditionnel ou pas
constitutionnel les deux interprétations
sont possibles il y en a probablement
une qui me plairait peut-être plus que
l'autre mais les deux interprétations
sont aussi je vous dirais pas la clé et
donc ce faisant bonne emballant le
Conseil constitutionnel là-dessus aura à
trancher et on revient sur la question
d'opportunités les arguments
d'opportunité ne pourront pas tout à
fait être absent du débat oui ce qui est
très intéressant le Conseil va trancher
en droit les français si je puis dire on
tranchait de manière politique ils ont
fait une évaluation alors tous les
différents règlements articles ont été
je dirais peu perçus par les Français
ils ont vu la masse
des amendements ils ont vu ils ont vu
surtout ce qui a été appelé la
bordélisation en tout cas le désordre à
l'Assemblée nationale et le contraste
s'agissant d'un débat plutôt serein
malgré tout au Sénat mais les Français
ont tranché politiquement sur une loi
dont sur une réforme dont je répète les
trois grandes critiques une fidélité qui
n'a jamais été comprise contrairement de
à 2010 2010 c'était simple c'était il
faut sauver le soldat retraite donc les
Français ont accepté cet effort
raisonnable de passer de 60 à 70 ans cet
effort jugé par eux à l'époque
raisonnable par une petite majorité une
réforme injuste une réforme injuste et
une réforme par rapport à laquelle on a
eu le sentiment que le gouvernement
n'avait parfois pas dit la vérité avec
caché les choses notamment ces fameux
1200 euros donc c'est pour ça que c'est
très intéressant une part
d'instrumentalisation de ce que va dire
et de ce qui est attendu par le Conseil
constitutionnel et le fait que il va
juger très de manière très décalé par
rapport à l'évaluation mais c'est tout à
fait normal de cette réforme par les
Français il y a un autre sujet que va
trancher le Conseil constitutionnel
aujourd'hui c'est la question du Rip se
référendum d'initiative partagée Quentin
c'est le deuxième enjeu de cette journée
voilà c'est porté par la gauche
sénatoriale et les députés de la nuque
cette demande de référendum vise je cite
à affirmer que l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite ne peut être fixé au-delà de
62 ans depuis plusieurs jours des
inquiétudes se multiplient à gauche les
parlementaires qui craignaient en fait
que leur première demande de référendum
elle était mal rédigée qu'elle soit
fragile la formulation ne pourrait pas
convenir au juge conditionnel on a donc
appris hier c'est-à-dire une information
publique Sénat la gauche qui a déposé
une deuxième demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée c'est
effectivement Patrick canard qui l'a
expliqué à publique Sénat nous avons
préféré sécuriser les choses après
analyse nous avons rédigé je cite un
texte qui a davantage qui est davantage
confort conforté en termes juridique
avec des arguments financiers afin de
porter une vraie proposition de réforme
est-il précisé public c'est marrant et
Quentin même avec ce deuxième RIB et
bien le chemin avant l'organisation d'un
vote et quand même se met dans du champ
bien sûr la proposition de loi
référendaire doit être signé par au
moins un cinquième des parlementaires
soit 185 élus ça pour le coup ce critère
il est rempli je crois qu'ils étaient
même plus nombreux à signer la deuxième
demande de RIP que la première et ils
sont plus de 230 je crois à signer le
deuxième RIP donc ça c'est bon mais
après le dépôt vient la validation par
le Conseil constitutionnel c'est ce
qu'on attend donc ce soir le texte doit
porter sur l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics sur des réformes relatives à la
politique économique sociale et ou
environnementale de la nation et au
service public qui concourent on verra
si la formulation convient sur les
termes employés par les parlementaires
et enfin vous le voyez il faut réunir
les signatures d'au moins 10% du corps
électoral en France ça donne 4, à 7
millions de Français qui devront
viennent plateforme en ligne ouverte par
le Conseil constitutionnel et bien signé
sur une période de 9 mois alors
seulement Oriane la proposition de loi
pourra faire l'objet d'un référendum mis
en place après la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 se mécanisme
législatif malgré plusieurs tentatives
n'a encore jamais abouti on le rappelle
il a une chance d'abouture cette fois
moi il faut dire que en 2008 ça a été
pensé créer construit pour ne jamais
aboutir mais un dispositif qui est un
dispositif de démocratie directe dans la
Constitution mais voyez bien en Italie
c'est 500 000 signatures là et ça doit
porter sur une loi qui vient d'être
votée alors que nous en France on a
considéré que justement ça devait
surtout pas porter sur une loi qui
venait d'être votée alors le Conseil a
été sympathique dans sa décision sur ADP
il a ménagé les choses pour que malgré
tout ce soit à peu près possible d'où le
fait que ça doit être reçu avant la
promulgation de la loi et ce sera pareil
c'est ça et une fois qu'il y a 4
millions 800 000 signatures ou 900 000
et bien c'est pas forcément référendum
si c'est examiné par le Parlement il n'y
a pas de référendum donc là il va y
avoir un dilemme alors est-ce que ça a
une chance d'aboutir le premier RIP
désolé de le dire ainsi et je vais me
faire peut-être des ennemis il est quand
même écrit avec les pieds et donc comme
il est écrit avec les pieds la
validation quand même le conseille le
voudrait et probablement à ses
problématiques le deuxième RIP n'est pas
mirifique mais malgré tout il y a on va
dire une réforme dedans on a rajouté la
CSG etc donc il est assez probable que
la gauche sentant que ces problématiques
a pris ces informations pour mettre en
place un rythme qui malgré tout est
valable par le Conseil constitutionnel
qui s'il valide la réforme aura quand
même peut-être à cœur de valider de
laisser une porte de sortie ce qui
permettrait bien également de trouver
une autre voie d'action selon vous
c'est-à-dire que le premier rythme
devrait être invalidé ce soir il
faudrait attendre que le second qui a
été annoncé hier soit voilà tranchée
plus tard alors je suis pas voilà je
suis pauvre il y a un mois mais ils
peuvent décider plutôt on peut
s'attendre à une décision probablement
dans 10 jours mais en soi il va en effet
y avoir une période de latence quoi
qu'il en soit 4 millions signatures
c'est beaucoup mais si vous regardez sur
ADP vous regardez les réseaux Europe
écologie des Verts et LFI ça correspond
exactement aux zones de signature là si
jamais vous avez toute la nuit place CGT
la CFDT FO plus peut-être même certains
partis de droite le RN va peut-être
tenter de jouer le jeu et bien vous
pouvez les avoir quand même les 4
millions 800 signatures c'est loin
d'être impossible et ça mettrait le
gouvernement dans une vraie difficulté
parce que la retraite à 62 ans par
référendum soit vous laissez passer le
référendum avec les yeux de Bruxelles et
des marchés sur vous qui risquent d'être
assez sévères soit vous décidez
d'invalier la chose par le Parlement en
faisant que le texte est rejeté devant
les chambres ou au moins examiner sans
être adopté auquel cas et bien ça veut
dire que la crise démocratique et la
crise sociale vous lancez une allumette
dans un baril de poudre Frédéric les
Français l'attendent l'espère se
réfèrent dans le sens où il souhaite
absolument enfin sortir de ce corner
dont j'ai parlé enfin tout à l'heure de
l'enquête il faut fiduciale pour SUD
RADIO on teste toute une série de
changements au sens large politique pour
clore cette séquence 73 % souhaitent la
mise en place d'un référendum
d'initiative partagé mais également 69 %
en remaniement force 61 une dissolution
c'est le reflet de ce sentiment de
blocage et l'idée qu'il faut sortir de
là je pense que pion publique n'a pas en
tête le le processus c'est de
cheminement long d'un éventuel RIP
maintenant c'est vrai que ce serait même
si ce serait compliqué pour le
gouvernement avec une épée de Damoclès
qui courrait sur 9 mois l'ambition de je
dirais commencer pour dans un sens ce
quinquennat d'enjamber de mettre à
distance de chlore cette séquence
calamiteuse en termes d'image en termes
d'approbation en termes de popularité
sur cette séquence des des retraites
sera absolument impossible à clore donc
c'est vrai que dans ce dans ce cadre là
c'est du carburant pour le moment social
de dire on peut continuer à faire des
manifestations perlées pour mobiliser
non pas contre la réforme mais contre
pour plutôt la signature et les 4008
c'est beaucoup de monde mais quand on
voit la part des Français qui sont
résolument opposés à la réforme parfois
sa tangente les 40 les 45% dans une
logique d'extrapolation ça fait 15 20
millions de personnes les 4 millions 9
sont beaucoup plus atteignables que au
moment d'ADP on était on avait je crois
à peine dépassé le million si je me
trompe pas donc ce serait vraiment
l'idée que ce quinquennat serait
parasiter pour ne pas dire phagocyté par
ce processus de référendum d'initiative
partagée et la posture d'Emmanuel Macron
qui malgré tout a réformer le pays à
travers une réforme emblématique serait
clairement mis à mal donc ce serait
vraiment extrêmement compliqué et puis 9
mois ça veut dire une campagne pour les
élections européennes premier scrutin
intermédiaire du quinquennat
dans un dans un halo de risques si je
peux dire pour les pouvoirs publics pour
le gouvernement d'un référendum oui vous
dites neuf mois Frédéric ces fans disent
même 15 puisqu'elle est neuf mois pour
récolter les les signatures et ensuite
il y a les six mois pour inscrire le
texte dans une des deux chambres du
Parlement donc ça lui il parlait même
des pets de Damoclès effectivement sur
le quinquennat pendant 15 mois où il y
aurait effectivement cette incertitude
autour de la suite du processus autour
de la réforme des retraites d'autant
qu'en cas de non censure totale ça
n'empêchera pas la réforme d'être mise
en oeuvre Benjamin non ça empêche pas
alors il y a cette idée qui courent que
on a suspendu pour ADP et que donc ça
met fin à la réforme en tout cas que ça
la suspens c'est pas vrai sur ADP le
gouvernement choisi de suspendre la
privatisation mais en aucun cas ni est
obligé donc qui plus est ça poserait
quand même une question à la fois en
termes d'égalité de sécurité juridique
parce qu'on aurait une réforme mis en
place qui pourrait être invalidé
quelques mois plus tard donc là en effet
il va y avoir un vrai vrai sujet pour le
gouvernement pour les administrations il
va falloir prendre rapidement les
décrets d'application tout ça dans une
situation d'incertitude forte ouais
parce que pour mettre fin une autre idée
qui court on entend beaucoup hein et de
la part des oppositions demander le
retrait de la réforme si ce soir le
conseil constitutionnel ne censure pas
totalement Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
d'autre choix que de la promulgaire
alors il a deux autres choix il doit
promulguer théoriquement il peut pas
s'abstenir de promulguer sinon ça
s'appelle un droit de veto c'était le
cas sous la monarchie dans la conscience
1791 on disait que le roi pouvait ne pas
sanctionner une loi mais personne n'a
réellement envie de revenir à la
monarchie vous voyez même l'opposition
ne devrait pas demander ça
fondamentalement mais il y a deux autres
options vous pouvez demander la seconde
délibération à la chambre c'est Liné à
deux de la Constitution on va la prendre
celui-là aussi bientôt et cet article là
vous permet de renvoyer la chose devant
les Chambres évidemment politiquement
est-ce que c'est pas suicidaire après
avoir utilisé un 49 aliné à 3 de
demander cette fois-ci à la chambre de
voter peut-être mais c'est une
possibilité l'autre option parce
qu'évidemment derrière il y a l'idée du
CPE c'est de dire certes je promis que
la loi elle existe c'est le droit mais
je demande aux administrations de ne pas
prendre les décrets d'application une
loi en tant que tel elle s'applique
rarement directement pour réellement
produire des effets dans le réel elle a
besoin de décret d'applications qui
viennent donner les ordres aux
administrations pour la mettre en place
si vous ne prenez pas les décrets
d'application à ce moment-là il n'y a
pas d'application mais pas y avoir de
retrait au sens ring du terme ça c'est
pas tu peux pas y avoir de retrait au
sens strict du terme ce qui est beau par
définition
on avait demandé de ne pas prendre les
décrets d'application et on en vient à
Frédéric à la question composée au début
quelles conséquence selon vous de la
décision ce soir du conseil personnel
sur la suite de la mobilisation oui il y
a une alternative soit bon on va on va
imaginer que le Conseil valide la
plupart des dispositifs de cette loi ça
peut être soit un coup d'arrêt fatale à
un moment social en perte de vitesse
quantitative il y avait quand même pas
gros monde dans les rues dans Paris même
la CGT était en deçà de son de la
journée
précédente puisque voilà la loi est
votée elle va être
faite promulguée elle n'est pas
censurée que cette décennale que cette
décélération s'accompagne d'un voilà
d'une petite mort de ce mouvement soit
et c'est pour ça que je parlais de 49-3
bis qui est un propre par rapport à ce
que ça représente mais ce serait un
nouveau carburant pour montrer cette
opposition à la réforme des retraites on
entend dire que ce n'est pas que le
Conseil constitutionnel ça a été dit par
des opposants que ce n'est il va pas
voter sur il va pas voter sur le fond
mais sur la forme sur la
constitutionnalité de la loi et donc en
rien ce Conseil constitutionnel
n'empêche de continuer des mobilisations
alors on verra la CFDT par rapport à la
nouvelle CGT avec Sophie Binet en tout
cas j'en parlais tout à l'heure dans
l'opinion publique on a quelque chose
que je trouve de très frappante
c'est-à-dire une sorte de fracturation
avec avec de France qui se font face
d'un côté une France plutôt
conservatrice des personnes âgées des
cas de supérieures sympathisants
Renaissance
LR voir une partie du RN qui dit bon les
manifestations devront cesser et d'autre
part à 52% c'est du 55 50 une France
plutôt active salarié cette France du
travail qui s'opposait à la réforme des
retraites proche de la gauche qui
considère que le conseil social n'aura
pas tranché les choses et donc la
mobilisation devra continuer donc ce qui
je pense que est compte tenu de cette
fracturation quand on est du fait qu'on
est 37% qui considèrent que les
mobilisations ne doivent pas du tout
s'arrêter donc c'est vraiment un
jugement beaucoup plus radical on peine
à imaginer que ce soir le rideau se
baisse soit complètement tiré il est 20
pour l'exécutif
ça sera peut-être une première étape
dans cette page tournée mais en tout cas
ça sera je pense ça ne sera en aucun cas
un rideau baissé sur cette période qui a
commencé ouais on peut
au mois de décembre et surtout à partir
du 15 janvier lors de la présentation
par Isabelle borne de cette réforme oui
au delà enfin je veux dire le les dégâts
politiques sont de toute façon
difficilement remédiable pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que le lien avec
les syndicats est détérioré de manière
peut-être pas définitive mais au moins
très longue donc négocier sur le travail
les services publics y compris avec
Laurent Berger va être très compliqué
dans les mois suivants quel que soit le
sort de cette réforme et ensuite il y a
plus de majorité parlementaire on en a
peu parlé mais il y a deux jours il
s'est quand même passé quelque chose
d'important le rip a été créé pour ne
jamais être utilisé un autre truc qui a
été créé pour ne jamais réellement
arriver au but c'était les contrôles des
nominations du président de la
République à l'article 13
exactement et le président de l'ADEME
chose qu'on aurait pas réellement cru on
pensait que c'était simplement formel et
bien sa nomination a été refusée par les
parlementaires ça c'est totalement
inédit ça interroge réellement ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui on est arrivé à un
point de défiance au sein du Parlement
que et bien gouverner pour le Premier
ministre et le président de la
République quel que soit le nom de là où
du prochain Premier ministre va être
extrêmement extrêmement difficile et que
on n'est même pas la première année du
quinquennat
à la question de ce quinquennat nos
échanges la comparaison avec le CPE
donne une impression de fin de règne à
travers une popularité en berne à
travers une personnalisation des
critiques des Français c'est vraiment
l'idée que c'est lui contre nous c'est
comme ça que les Français en parlent
alors que nous ne sommes même pas au
premier anniversaire du second tour du
24 avril et de la nouvelle entrée en
fonction des manuels Macron donc
nécessité pour l'exécutif de tourner au
plus vite cette page d'un référend des
retraites et par rapport à des échanges
on voit que cette page n'est pas encore
complètement tournée et loin de là et on
suivra bien sûr ça tout au long de la
journée sur Public Sénat on va voir
l'actualité dans nos régions grâce à nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Bourges retrouver Gladys Lafitte
bonjour Gladys merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Ré dactrice en chef adjointe
au Berry Républicain on va parler d'un
tout autre sujet on va s'aérer un petit
peu avec vous Gladys c'est les vacances
de printemps et c'est l'occasion pour
vous de mettre l'accent sur le boom du
tourisme dans le Cher
exactement nous aussi on est évidemment
dans l'attente de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel mais dans l'attente
voilà on a envie un peu de s'aérer de se
détendre et donc on vous propose de
venir dans le Cher qui est un
département qui est évidemment en vogue
en ce moment parce que on bénéficie de
la ruralité d'un patrimoine exceptionnel
on est à moins 2 heures de Paris et
c'est vrai que du coup on a une
fréquentation qui augmente on a plus 40%
de visiteurs l'année dernière par
rapport à l'année d'avant c'est aussi
plus que la Vanco vide les visiteurs
reviennent les étrangers les visiteurs
de la clientèle d'affaires et donc pour
ça on vous propose notamment de voir nos
plus belles balades à vélo c'est vrai
qu'on a un réseau de berges qui s'est
énormément développé ces derniers temps
on a donc créé en partenariat avec le
Conseil départemental et le comité
départemental du cyclotourisme un guide
c'est une première un guide spécial qui
vous permet effectivement d'avoir des
itinéraires sur le moins cher à vélo
donc on a 42 cartes 35 itinéraires c'est
assez inédit ça a été écrit et
coordonnée par Arnaud Pasquier qui a
fait un travail exceptionnel puisqu'il y
a 148 pages des photos aussi magnifique
pour vous donner envie vous verrez ces
vers il y a de l'eau il y a du
patrimoine il y a des clochers il y a
des colombages il y a vraiment tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer dans le Cher des
photos magnifiques de Pierrick de Lobel
notamment de la rédaction ça coûte 6,90
c'est vendu dans les kiosques et donc on
vous en parle dans le Berry Républicain
aujourd'hui aussi puisque le département
profite de cet essor du cyclotourisme on
sait que la France c'est la deuxième
c'est le deuxième pays mondial pour le
cyclotourisme on a 22 millions quand
même de visiteurs qui font du vélo
pendant leurs vacances en France donc
c'est énorme voilà comme le dit très
bien Arnaud dans notre article on
profite un petit peu d'un alignement des
planètes il y a l'urgence climatique qui
est la prise de conscience écologique il
y a le progrès technique et surtout il y
a une volonté politique forte de
développer ce qu'on appelle ce slow
tourisme donc voilà on vous propose de
visiter nos trois provinces la Touraine
le Berry le Bourbonnais avec une partie
de la Loire à Vélo puisqu'on a quand
même 70 km dans notre département un
petit mot Gladys puisque c'est
l'événement à Bourges à partir de mardi
le début du Printemps de Bourges
oui c'est l'événement annuel on attend
énormément de visiteurs cette année ça
commence mardi dès le début de la
semaine on vous a proposé des articles
évidemment d'artistes qui vont se
produire notamment hier dans le journal
d'hier on avait m Mathieu Chedid qui
ouvrira le Printemps de Bourges ce mardi
demain dimanche pardon vous retrouverez
Jeanne Added et puis sur notre site le
Berry
républicain.com vous pourrez retrouver
également Juliette Armanet voilà tous
ces artistes qui vont se produire
Lomepal également donc on vous attend
nombreux et ça va être aussi un moment
très fort dans notre ville et on viendra
vous voir Gladys surtout qu'on parle
parce que Quentin est content il a très
envie de venir vous voir
vous avez fait un super travail de voilà
pour nous vendre ce numéro spécial sur
le vélo dans le Cher ça donne
extrêmement envie de l'avoir voilà et
voilà il va venir on regarde la une les
plus belles balades à vélo dans le Cher
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Gladys je crois que vous avez
donné envie à beaucoup d'aller dans le
Cher merci une petite chanson peut-être
Frédéric merci
Frédéric Benjamin Quentin je sais que
vous avez la réponse est-ce que vous
connaissez le breaking
des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 ça
vient de chir nous emmène découvrir
cette discipline qui devient sport
olympique pour la première fois c'est
plus connu sous le nom de breakdance une
branche du hip-hop
ça il est danseurs qui devrait défendre
les couleurs de la France on regarde ok
Google
[Musique]
dans le temple du sport de haut niveau
le breaking branche du hip-hop
caractérisée par ses figures au sol
devient une discipline olympique
inscrite au programme des Jeux 2024 à
Paris la crème des bboys et big girls
français s'entraînent à l'INSEP le
centre de préparation des meilleurs
athlètes de France sous la direction
d'Oma remichi alias bboy chacal champion
du monde 2019 on rentre dans un modèle
hyper pro avec toutes les hygiène de vie
derrière tout un travail de performance
donc c'est très intéressant moi je
trouve que c'est quelque chose de
positif il y a le côté financier
derrière alors là on est aidé on est
aidé par l'État pour justement se
concentrer et être juste focus à
préparer le championnat et une
compétition
être entretenu par rapport à tout ce qui
arrive avec par rapport à nos blessures
par rapport à nos juste nos situations
financières et personnelles donc il y a
quand même une prise en charge qui nous
aide un peu être vraiment focus pour la
compétition
danseur suite un programme de
préparation très exigeant pour espérer
décrocher une place au toute première
épreuve olympique de breakdance l'an
prochain parmi les espoirs de médaille
sarahbi 33 ans c'est une opportunité de
malade je pense c'est ouf et puis les
Jeux Olympiques ça reste quand même
ça reste quand même un événement
incroyable et là il est à Paris il est
chez nous donc monter sur un podium
ramené une médaille pour notre pays qui
n'aimerait pas le faire quoi c'est je
pense que c'est c'est devenu un rêve
pour nous parce que c'est vrai qu'à la
base on en rêvait pas parce que c'était
pas accessible c'était pas possible et
maintenant que c'est possible et c'est
que ça accessible bah du coup
c'est c'est ouf en fait on a envie en
fait on a envie de représenter la France
et de donner le meilleur de nous-mêmes
32 danseurs dont 16 femmes et ses hommes
seront sélectionnés aux Jeux Olympiques
2024 pour s'affronter dans ce qu'on
appelle des battles du 1 contre 1 ou les
beagles et boys improvisent chacun leur
tour sur le son d'un DJ qu'il ne
connaissent pas à l'avance
départagés par des juges leur
performances seront diffusées dans le
monde entier on va toucher plus de monde
du coup parce que là la visibilité elle
va être énorme elle va être mondiale et
puis ça va être ça va être
des gens lambda qui vont nous regarder
danser qui qui vont aussi découvrir le
brique donc je pense que ça va ça va un
gros impact
avec cinq danseurs classés dans le top
16 au dernier mondiaux la France qui
dansera à domicile a de sérieuses
chances de décrocher l'une des premières
médailles olympiques de l'histoire du
breaking
[Rires]
[Musique]
constitutionnel en feront enfin je veux
dire il y a peut-être répond à
construire le breaking on peut les
inviter à se mettre au maximum en
attendant content regarde ce qu'il y a
la Une on reparle du Conseil
constitutionnel dans la presse régionale
[Musique]
et Quentin ça y est on redevient sérieux
de nombreux titres ce matin reviennent
sur le compte à rebours qui a commencé
avant la décision du Conseil constitut
oui le temps que Oriane les une sont
très solennelles ce matin dans la presse
quotidienne régionale regardez La
Dépêche c'est le grand jour le Conseil
constitutionnel va rendre sa décision
très attendue sur la réforme voyez un
beau coup de une dernière nouvelle
d'Alsace qui titres sur l'heure du
verdict le Midi Libre à Montpellier qui
reprend le mot d'ailleurs Verdi clairse
républicain à Nancy qui parle d'un
vendredi crucial la Nouvelle République
à Tours titre sur une décision sous
pression ils étaient 4000 personnes
d'ailleurs à Tours toujours la même idée
avec le Républicain Lorrain vous le
voyez à Metz avec une décision attendue
de pied ferme et enfin on termine avec
le Télégramme en Bretagne et ses mots
réforme ou censure puisque c'est tout
l'enjeu certains journaux reviennent
particulièrement sur la 12e journée de
mobilisation qui se tenait oui et voyez
avec en plus parfois et bien les
informations qui se croisent le bien
public à Dijon qui lance un pronostic et
bien que ce n'était pas la dernière en
plus cette mobilisation hier et dès
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le journal
explique que l'Inter cervicale a appelé
à des rassemblements citoyens sud-ouest
qui parle de grogne en attendant les
sages vous le voyez et enfin Paris
Normandie raconte la détermination des
manifestants d'ailleurs on peut
s'arrêter un instant sur le titre
normand dans les pages intérieures le
journal qui parle d'une colère qui reste
vive et l'éditorialiste journal Stéphane
ciré qui écrit le dialogue de sourd
risque de se poursuivre un bon moment
encore la Provence à Marseille revient
sur le drame qui s'est joué le week-end
dernier voilà je vous conseille la
lecture de l'article pour et bien voir
que avance très vite on voit que c'est
bien explosion au gaz a priori qui a
causé le drame qui a tué huit personnes
la semaine dernière on
termine l'eau dans le Cher qu'on a vu
avec Gladys mais on va terminer
effectivement avec une passion de
beaucoup de Français c'est la brocante
ou encore les vide-greniers et bien la
saison a démarré dit la montagne et ce
jusqu'en septembre vous voyez le titre
de la montagne bon plan anti-inflation
utile pour vider ses placards ils sont
aussi une source de revenus pour les
associations organisatrices et en plus
c'est écolo
ben voilà une passion française
chez moi
fin de cette émission spéciale consacrée
à la décision du Conseil constitue mais
vous suivrez évidemment cette actu toute
la journée sur Public Sénat à 18h vous
avez rendez-vous avec Thomas Hugues pour
une autre édition spéciale et on devrait
connaître la décision à ce moment-là il
analysera tout ça avec ses invités on se
retrouve lundi notre invité politique ce
sera Olivier fort le premier secrétaire
du PSA lundi
[Musique]